I'm here for all of the incredible
protectors protesters activists
attorneys organizers that are
sacrificing an incredible incredibly
great deal to be heard and to get access
to equal rights and justice in this
country Grey's Anatomy star Jesse
Williams steals the Beatty Awards with
his impassioned speech on civil rights
if you have no interest in equal rights
for black people then do not make
suggestions to those who do on Sunday
the 34 year old actor received BET's
Humanitarian Award for his tireless
activism in the black lives matter
movement we are gonna have equal rights
and justice in our own country or we
will restructure their function Jesse
dedicated his speech to his parents wife
and the leaders around the country
working hard to enact change his message
was poetic and profound burying black
people out of sight and out of mind
while extracting our culture our dollars
are entertainment like oil black gold
ghettoizing and demeaning our creations
than stealing them gentrifying our
genius and then trying us on like
costumes before discarding our bodies
like rinds of strange fruit before the
show et was with Jesse on the silver
carpet he opened up about being a father
and candidly revealed this my personal
lived experience doesn't necessarily
fuel my ability to see humanity in the
places and the places that they tell us
it doesn't learn we ask others to see
themselves in us and we should be able
to see ourselves in others